[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
what's up guys I am Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me welcome
back to the dope as usual podcast I'm
here with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's
up guys getting straight into it guys
legendary episode look at Marty's face
I'm hyped
rapper and now I would say author this
is the Jeezy episode thank you for being
here yeah this is dope appreciate y'all
having make sure you add entrepreneur in
there too entrepreneurs and
philanthropist yo this is all the above
big man yeah yeah yeah it's a whole
different level thank you guys for
having me man thank you appreciate you
pulling up I'm supposed to be here thank
you anyways dope as usual I should be
pulling up yeah yeah that's what I want
to hear for sure um real quick the first
uh question I want to ask because I know
Marty you know Ashley Marty go for it
you start with your question first well
I was just so excited that first of all
to have you on here and second of all
under these circumstances like just like
you said with the tip of the spirit
being this motivational entrepreneurial
Innovative yes new book coming out
August 8th University for sale yes you
got to believe now recently we were the
first podcast Duo ever in Ted talk to go
do a speech on entrepreneurship oh wow
yeah so last January we went and did
that our speech was called definition of
a hustler okay the topic of the night
what skills do you need to survive in
the digital age when starting from
scratch or basically if you lost
everything how could you get yourself
back right and I kind of feel like this
is the Hustler's motivational Anthem
right here you know it's like the uh the
mental GPS
so if you get lost to get you back on
track I like that yeah yeah that's dope
that's dope we uh I mean I don't want to
Spill the whole book right but I want to
ask one question okay Mr Russell reminds
me of Fred Sanford you know straight up
I was reading like this is France we
were watching Sanford and Son yeah when
they sent it to us yeah yeah the all all
in his fingernails and you know it's
crazy because he was probably one of the
first entrepreneurs I ever released I
didn't know it was an entrepreneur but
he had properties he had a shop uh he
had you know people renting out
apartments from him you know I mean just
old early like oily guy you know what
I'm saying and uh but it was crazy just
being around him because he he had a
sensitive Direction even back then
because you got to think town was small
2500 people at the most but here you
have this guy that lives on you know the
corner that owns most of the block and
he has a mechanic shop you know in in
the neighborhood and he's you know got
soda machines and snacks you can buy so
he was thinking money back then right
when everybody else was just working at
factories so that's one of the reasons
why I wanted to kind of be around them
but as you know I was trying to steal
that car radio for a car I didn't have
quite yet but I wanted the radio no you
wanted it yeah yeah you can't do nothing
with it but you know you wanted it yeah
that's like stealing keys to your car
you don't have yeah you don't have you
just want the keys though yeah
motivation it's something yeah um all
right what's the first time you like the
first car you ever bought because I know
you did it young probably yeah I mean I
had cars in my life but I think the
first car actually really owned was a
car that my dad used to drive it was a
Buick Regal it's blue Buick Regal and um
I remember you know it was it was shot
so he fixed the engine on it and I still
remember the headline was falling from
the ceiling and you had to hold the
brakes when you put it in reverse
because of the the transmission or
whatever and I just drive me and my
homie to school uh anyways go to like I
think it was Middle School like eighth
night Middle School the car yeah
but you know I couldn't Park on campus
so we parked like down the street stand
up right but you know we had this car we
barely had gas in it and uh and what we
did was I had the two knob uh radio in
there and we listened to Tupac thug life
like like the the the one he had with
the group the album thug life we're
listening that to and from school every
day you know what I'm saying straight
balling uh uh all the joints he had on
there uh don't get don't get it twisted
but it was like the thing because
um you know and of course this is before
I started getting calls on my own but I
just had this car and it's just like if
we could just scrape up two dollars to
to put some gas in it to drive back and
forth to school that was enough I
remember yeah yeah 500 blunt right those
are the days yeah we didn't have quite
enough to get no weed though I mean your
eighth and Ninth Grade yeah yeah yeah
yeah we was trying to smoke here and
there but it's just like you know if he
was lucky to get a joint you know what
I'm saying I would imagine the weed
situation oh way different it was so
there's so many seeds and stuff in there
like it's not what you guys smoking
today for sure yeah is that what you
bought from your uncle in the vanilla
envelope oh and as a matter of fact I
remember this I remember this for I had
this Uncle uh his name was Robert and he
ended up getting a life sentence early
so he was going for life and he had a
brother named Nick and Nick was like the
weed man cool guy player you know got
all the women and I remember when I did
my first uh CD it was called Lil Jay
thugging on the m influence and I
remember it was out one day I was a
little older and I was like yo Nick you
know grab one of my CDs he was like he
got looked at he's like
you can buy one of these these dime bags
you know what I'm saying but he wouldn't
even support damn my my you know my my
um my passion what what I was doing at
the time but I never forget it I
remember I went back and um we went back
to uh my little cousin's graduation
party and I pulled up I had uh my driver
I had uh the musane the big one though
the big extra uh uh the extra back move
saying so I got about extra six inches
on it and um we drove down and I pulled
up my driver hopped out suited and
booted and came around opened my door I
hopped out I was like what's up Nick but
I can just see the look on his face like
damn you know what I'm saying I should
have supported him so I'll tell anybody
out there man stay with your dreams man
they ain't always right you know they
can look at you and doubt you but they
don't know oh you know yeah only you
know yeah they don't know they don't
know of course but how old are you
having a driver oh no this was when I
actually got on oh yeah no no no no no
no no this was like a couple years ago
oh yeah yeah
okay I went back to the hood and I you
know how much because I'm established
now so I go back I got my driver and my
security everybody and uh you know I hop
out and you know my driver get up and
open the door you good Mr Jenkins and I
just look at Nick I know what's up Nick
and I just looked at his face he was
like damn you know he's still doing with
the same time yeah
he probably still selling dime bags you
know what I'm saying so yeah that's that
so you go back to a small town your town
I mean I read something I read I read it
so right I thought my town was Tiny yeah
my wife's from a town of like six
thousand oh wow but you're less than
that yeah for sure for sure nothing but
drugs and trying to do something drugs
and um it was drugs and by the way this
town was I don't know why but it was um
geographically just a hub right because
there were so many other small towns
around it and that's how when I got into
the hustling game I was able to venture
out and get money that was you know that
wasn't in the town because there was so
many surrounding areas and um but that
town was basically known for the factory
jobs they had like a couple of factory
jobs like Frito-Lay and something else I
think some kind of uh cotton meal or
something like that and that's where
everybody was prided in it was just like
yo you know I got a job I'm making five
dollars an hour I'm like an hour
the hell we gonna do with that it's so
in my mind you know because I was um
when I was young my dad was in the
military so I lived in Hawaii I lived in
Japan oh you've been traveling yeah with
that kid the Army brat kids yep and so
when my mom and dad divorced I had to
move back to the hood so I knew that
there was beaches and and I knew that
there was you know like uh palm tree
like nobody in the hood knew that
they're like what are you talking about
so my whole mission was to get back to
that so that's what started my Pursuit
because I'm just like I got to get back
to what I know and I figured you know
when I started seeing the hustling I'm
like okay here's an Avenue so I started
that and of course it ended you know it
brought me to music but then I Knew
music wasn't the end I'll be all because
you know music is a talent that I have
but my passion was always business right
but I knew I couldn't just come from the
Block and go into a ballroom so I'm just
like how do I figure this out but then I
I'm not I don't regret anything because
I feel like everything that I learned in
the streets it it helps me today right
of course everything yeah everything you
know just be in a different situation
and being able to like foresee how it
could play out and if it doesn't play
out that way I'm prepared for the worst
and then I'm already thinking of plan b
or what else I need to do to recover and
then also not being
um
um emotional about it right because I
understand it's all in the game and that
helped me out a lot in business so when
I started doing business I'll be in
these board rooms in these meetings you
know people be frantic because they they
trying to work it out I'm just going why
don't we just try this and then it
worked and they're like
like it's as simple as simple as that
yeah is a b line from A to Z that's it
you just walk it and you just gotta
trust and believe that what you thought
of and by the way
that's 99 of what the book is about
that's why I say adversity for sale
because they're all thoughts it's just
thoughts like you you're thinking
through things right because you don't
have a product to sell you know you
don't have a you don't have a tangible
right you know I'm saying these are just
ideas you're coming up with and you're
either a turning it into a play or you
be turning it into a business right and
it's all unorthodox because it hasn't
been done before your way so your your
trailblazing as you go and you're
figuring it out right so you're gonna
bump your head right and I think the the
the the beauty the beauty of the
adversity part is that's where all the
knowledge was I wouldn't want to tell
you success for sale because that
doesn't like anybody's gonna have
success but you got us this you gotta
sustain it right and if you can't
sustain it you already know what that is
but the knowledge and the wisdom is in
the losses because now you can sit back
and you got the data and you got to go
hmm okay well maybe you have to talk to
this person next time and go about it
this way and as a matter of fact I'm
gonna
go have this meeting and I'm gonna
figure that out and I'm gonna go
um rub elbows over here because when I
get ready to do it I'm gonna need their
supporting it and now you you thinking
of a bigger in a broader plan because
your first thought might have been the
right way of thinking but it might have
been the wrong timing right and then the
wrong people involved so now you got to
look at it different and fix the pieces
or move on to something else knowing
that you know how this feel so your next
thing you got to be a little more
smarter so that's why I say adversity
for sale because that's that's where
it's at that's that's the real that's
the real fruit that's that's that's
that's what's hanging from the tree you
know 100 yeah that's where everything
comes like uh my next question was I
know
entrepreneur philanthropist you're an
author yes right and it's been years and
years since you've been doing any of the
trapping and stuff any of that I used to
sell pack small life that I started
making videos 10 years ago wow I just
stopped
I know there's a little it's not like
you miss it but it's more like I just
like watching [__] fly right do you ever
do you ever like in the back of your
mind like yeah [__] was fun dangerous
but damn it was fun not even the money I
tell you yeah but I tell you what
happened it um
really
you know fulfill me is what I learned
about real estate
because it's the same thing you're
taking something you're buying something
right you flip it if you like you keep
it if you like but you're taking cash
money and you're buying something right
and it has its value so you you continue
to do that and it accumulates more paper
than you buying these uh these cash
flowing assets and it's like your
money's working for you so it's no
different than having a trap house it's
like it that's one of my houses that
make money that's one of my houses that
make money this is my duplex is is
the most exciting and fascinating thing
I've ever seen like I I like like real
estate is like that's like my you know
how you got friends that play video
games I don't do that but I'll play Real
Estate all day yeah on the way over here
I was on the phone my relative we trying
to buy this Warehouse I'm like yo okay
but go back in and tell them this this
is fun you know it's like the highlight
of my day I'm gonna come sit with you
guys but I'm like you know I'm gonna
it's like it's like a drug deal like
seriously I loved it right I was trying
to realize your first time uh real
estate it's like your best investment
you've made well no I've done I've done
a lot of other stuff so I don't know if
people know like I actually was a part
owner of Avion tequila oh so yeah so
when we built it and we sold it to
Panola car so that was like one of my
bigger bigger bigger deals like that was
like life changing uh because I built
this brand and we saw YouTube yeah and
we both sold it to um uh one of the
biggest uh uh uh uh guys to do that
which is Panora car and then my business
partner which was my mentor he went on
to do
um
proper 13 with Conor McGregor all the
terrible and Terra Muno with uh Rock and
also he just did something with Jayla
and then I went on after we sold that to
do uh my Venture with uh nod Spirits
which out of not uh cognac France and
these are my new business partners and
they have they they distiller you know
any top brand you know because they're
Distillery five generations oh they're
like a white labeling yeah yeah and now
they got their own brand so I'm the one
that's helping them uh build it in the
U.S so that was my he went there I went
there but those are some of the bigger
things I did I've done bigger things but
um real estate is is my stronghold you
ever seen somebody's uh their pie like
their graph uh some people have you know
35 45
stock market and then you know yeah ten
percent this and that I would say real
estate is like my
40 45 because I've coined it in a way
that I understand it and anytime I make
a lump sum of money that's the first
place I go to like I don't like the
stock market is a little weird in the
Bitcoin thing just threw me off like I I
I'm way too I can't I don't want to look
at my phone and have a bad day you know
yeah I don't want to look at my phone
and wake up and be like mad at the world
so that was like a big one thing but but
real estate is so safe bro like if you
do it the right way yeah it's slow money
but it's for show money yeah and it's
almost like rather than you to park your
money in the bank just park it in real
estate because it's gonna always
accumulate and especially if you got
cash flowing assets it's gonna cash flow
like and it doesn't matter because the
goal is to have these assets uh take
care of your lifestyle or something and
you just really live off that you know
what I'm saying and anything else you do
as a plus yeah so if you go out here and
you close some deal for whatever that's
money you could just put to the side
yeah you're not even worried about and
the thing about it for me is it's just
like us it's crazy it's like if I knew
that before I think I would have took
the other route I don't think so
commercial real estate
but if I knew that before I think before
I went to the streets I would have tried
to borrow some money from somewhere and
been buying and flipping houses like at
a young age because I was and by the way
I grew up in a two bedroom trailer this
room is bigger than where I grew up at
me and my mom and my sister and are
where we live was smaller than you know
what I'm saying and it was you know like
I think we paid 3 500 and all for it so
just imagine that so when you get some
type of finances like you like I'm gonna
buy I'm never gonna be homeless the one
thing you can get into with no degree
just yeah yeah my wife's been a realtor
for the past 15 years or so we just
bought our first house and now it's like
our next goal is we want to build a
neighborhood yeah for sure that's where
we set our start time the next time yeah
why not yeah yeah he's from Buffalo so
buying house here or go buy a block in
Buffalo that's a lot more reasoning but
one thing about it boys it's gangster
out there dog yeah
it's going down in Buffalo man I'm like
what in the hell yeah y'all trying to
show out there I was just like wow
on deck on Deck yeah yeah and I'm trying
to buy my first house in my hometown my
house I grew up in okay the guy told me
no today he wouldn't sell with you I won
up there and I was like yo help me with
this guy he don't speak English man and
the neighbor's like yo what's up he said
no and I just left that was it I've been
trying to buy I'm gonna I'm gonna bug
him every couple months just wait it out
every couple weeks it's gonna be a time
because what I want to do is build a
nice house in the back of my old house
and use that one as Christmas like we
used to do everybody over there yeah and
it would feel like you know we're back
in 1993 yeah and you gotta you gotta
yeah because I ride past the trailer
that when I when I go visit family I
ride past the trail we used to live and
I'll go right man you have to I remember
sitting on the porch I remember walking
around the backyard
um but you know it it also keeps you uh
uh balanced as well you know what I'm
saying because sometimes you kind of get
caught up in what you're doing and the
success you're having and sometimes you
just need that that just remind her like
where you came from and why you got to
stay focused and keep your you know keep
it solid because a lot of times you know
that sex that success come and
everything changed and everybody around
you just around you and you just you
know what I mean you kind of just going
through the motions but you forget where
you came from you know if you're not
careful you know yeah I noticed you
follow Robert Kiyosaki on Instagram is
there he wrote uh
Robin Robert Greene I might be getting
his name wrong yeah Robert Greene uh is
there anybody like that that you any
audible podcasts is there people use man
we get into this so let me tell you
about Robert Greene uh Robert Green is
my guy when I'm in La
um when I come out here to do what I do
we always go to the uh uh Los Angeles
Athletic Club and we sit down and we
have lunch and tea and I ask them seven
questions it's crazy seven every time
yeah he's he's brilliant bro like
honestly
brilliant but he's like somebody you sit
there you just the whole time she's like
what he's going to say next Robert is
amazing uh John Maxwell which is uh uh
one of my great friends and Mentor as
well
um I don't know if you heard of John
Maxwell he's next level so he's like the
one that goes and fix all these things
with world leaders but he's a leadership
and a motivational uh speaker he used to
be a pastor but he's uh he's world
renowned that's another one um
I love Lewis house like Lewis is my guy
yeah yeah no Lewis yeah Lewis is a
podcast his podcast is it's next level
oh he actually hit me and told me
congratulations on the book uh Ed mylett
is another one I love
um and these are guys that talk about
everything from business to culture to
to health to everything so it's just
like I like to tap in on that and um I
got a bunch of authors I really like uh
I'm reading this book right now uh the
everyday hero Manifesto
probably one of the best books I read in
a long time other than mine
but I'm just one of those guys like I
had to she gotta understand like I came
from the streets and the way that I was
because this is what I noticed early on
I noticed that none of the guys that I
was hanging with really liked the old
guys you know the guys that are in their
60s or whatever
yeah that's what I could I would just go
and sit and be a fly and just listen to
them talking and ask questions be like
okay what's up with this you know tell
me things and I'll leave like field like
I was full I had more info than I came
with so I noticed that early so when I
started running to jams when I was
coming from the streets to the music
what I would do is I was just always
remember somebody I met in my life that
was from a different Walk of Life and
then I just tried to go set up lunch or
something with them and just talk to
them about things and just see their
perspective because they're on the
outside looking in and the advice they
would give you or or the information
they'll give you is not from your world
so it just makes it gives you a just
makes you look at things different right
of course and I started to learn that
and as I grew and every time I got into
a jam I don't know what it is it was
coming from the big homie up above you
always give me this thing and it just
comes in my head I should call and I
call this person hey what's up what you
doing man like what are you doing Friday
yeah we're gonna hang out we talk and
and I just ask my questions I got those
seven questions I just I'm gonna pay for
the dinner lunch whatever it is and I
got seven questions different questions
every time give them a question
different parts of your life different
phases and different things I need to
work through it's like Ted Talk told us
they're like you're a master at one
specific idea not one specific idea is a
group of like neurons in your brain you
can transfer those neurons they're not
on somebody else's brain when you walk
them through that idea that's what
you're walking away with time Southern
and they're giving you their Insight so
now you got somebody to process it with
because the problem I was running into
was nobody that was around me at the
time was I don't want to say on that
level of thinking but they had other
things on their mind I'm thinking of the
next level of thing that I need to do
because I'm already seeing that this is
drying up here so I'm like okay what do
I do now so as I'm talking to people I'm
starting oh okay well and you start
getting this information and now when
you go into these rooms I mean it's
crazy because I tell anybody like me and
Nipsey hustle was talking one day and he
was like yeah I gotta have I gotta have
equity in it I was like what the hell is
that you know what I'm saying we just
started talking yeah so when it was time
to do that I'll be on deal I didn't know
I was like yeah I lead Equity
that's what he did he's like come on man
I was like no I'm serious I said what do
you want to say I said what do you want
to uh I said he's like I'm gonna give
you a check I said no no you keep your
money when do you want to sell he said
in five years I said all right pay me
then let's sit down let's work out a
number and you pay me when you sell you
don't have to pay me anything Tim let me
show you what I can do and I did
everything but the conversation started
with Nipsey wow that's great he just put
someone put something else yeah I think
you know everything bro what is that
right he's been the most brought up
person on our show ever again somehow or
motivate some give them advice across
the board yeah Nipsey but he was um you
know and that's and that's what I feel
like y'all should be it's just like as
you get this knowledge you know which is
one of the reasons why I wrote the book
is like you got to give it back you
can't just you know they say that you
know the the most wealthiest place in
the world the cemetery the graveyard all
the knowledge is there the people dying
with it they don't want to share it you
know I'm saying you have to share it
that's one thing I can't say about nip
[__] was the first person to tell me
about Bitcoin
threw me off I was like what he was like
hit his coin imaginary right I didn't go
for it but he was the first he's the
first person I heard it from and as he
went on I started hearing it and then I
as it went on I started talking to some
of my guys who really are in the Western
World and they're just like that's too
volatile and I'm like okay let me go
look this word up I looked it up I was
like okay now
you know more right yeah you guys ever
make music together yeah yeah we made a
couple songs together and it's crazy
because actually in my road to be an
entrepreneur I was a executive at
Atlantic Records
um and I worked under
um
um all those big guys over there from uh
uh uh uh Craig Cowman to uh Julia uh uh
what's your name Julia green
she's like the big dog up there and I my
first thing get in there I was trying to
sign Nipsey hustle to Atlantic Records
and uh I was close to doing it and uh
the big guy over there uh
um
his name uh he's like the big dog he was
over there uh lior lior called me one
day when I was over Craig Campbell house
he was just like yo Jeezy because he's
like this Russian mob here talking
attack dude yo Jeezy I know you want to
sign Nipsey to the label but I can't let
you do it you and Ross are at odds and
Ross is my guy and I was like what the
hell that guy do what we doing and so
they didn't do the deal for me now mind
you they turned around about four months
later without telling me and they signed
them on their own right you know but he
but Nipsey was a g because he comes like
yo I did this deal I'm just letting you
know he said I'm not gonna tell anybody
about it until like a year from now
because I'm doing this Marathon out and
when he put out the album he that's when
he announced he had the deal so he
waited a year wow to tell somebody he
had a deal he had to deal for a year
yeah it was crazy damn that's Cramer
they did that too yeah yeah one thing I
learned about the music industry man is
is one million times worse than the
street damn there's no there's no code
on it there's no values there's more no
moral compass it's it's like the worst
you know if you're not sharp or you're
not smart you're gonna get got that's
from the lawyers to the executives to
everything management I'm saying just
like you have to be in that that's why
when I see a lot of people like smoking
and drinking and popping I'm like man
you better watch your money bro yep you
know what I'm saying and that's when
they coming because you're not in tune
with what's going on you know what I'm
saying it's just like even for me I
learned that early in the streets when I
was hustling I was very disciplined so I
didn't really drink or smoke
you know what I'm saying because I just
wanted to be focused and uh because I
because I just knew that I couldn't lose
man I didn't want to go to jail I didn't
want to get I didn't want to get killed
like so I'm just like I gotta be focused
and when I started seeing people go to
jail I was like oh this [__] it's real
you know and that that kind of scared me
a little bit you know what I'm saying
because it's just like I'm not the
prison type I'm you know
I'm a thinker I'm a disrupter I can't
think of disrupting the prison I'm not
gonna be able to make any changes
right yeah that'll kill me more than
anything exactly yeah I'm like that and
I'm claustrophobic by the way just see
oh yeah
I don't like to be in small spaces for a
long time I just ain't with it yeah but
what I really took from the book was
because like growing up in Buffalo like
the same exact [__] the factories you
get out of high school it's like the old
steel factories people accept that or
they don't but where I think we're very
similar is you had that inner
conversation going with the alerts going
off like this isn't for me yeah it's
impossible this everybody thinks I'm
insane I'm hopeless but I'm gonna take
this 20 sack and flip it up to where
we're at today basically yeah can you
talk on how you you're in a conversation
how you talk to yourself even back then
to now even if you look at my phone
right now I think my man got my phone I
got a picture of myself uh when I was
five on my phone right that I talk to
every day good homie I got you what you
need because there was a lot of things
in my childhood that I missed out on
because I was forced to be an adult at
such a young age right and so I had to
figure it out you know to my mom's my
sister and our well-being but the
conversation that was going on in my
head was that I had this because I felt
this like fire in my stomach like every
day like just burning it was telling me
it was like a furnace like you gotta go
you got to get it you got to figure it
out so I didn't sleep much you know I
was always if I wasn't hustling I was
moving and shaking and meeting new
people so I could move and shake some
more and the dialogue and the
conversation that was going on in my
head it's like I got to get us out of
here I got I got to change the dynamic I
gotta because if I don't ain't nobody
coming to save us yeah we're stuck you
know what I'm saying and that was the
everyday thing in my head like I got to
figure out a way how to get out of here
I got to figure out a way to get more
money I got to figure out a way to
because I moved times at different small
cities and and you know got my thing on
there and had to deal with whatever was
going on there so it was a lot of that
and then a lot of a lot of staying
discipline so that I could be safe
because I was in different type of
environments because I went from small
cities now I'm in the bigger cities and
it's gangs and it's this and that so now
I got to be a different type of Focus
right now I got to have different types
of conversations and now I got to really
vet out people that I'm bringing around
me yeah you know what I'm saying it's
different you know and and as far as
Atlanta goes like my cousins and my
aunties then was there so when I got to
Atlanta because I had been going every
summer anyway so I got back to Atlanta
it was just it was a different ball game
now you in a city where everybody
getting and having money but everybody
snake and it's it's different you know
and it's like you can't trust and you
can't let people in it's like I was in
Atlanta for like years and nobody even
knew where I stayed [__] I didn't know
where I stayed
it's just like you know it was like that
but um right now to this day that's the
dialogue that's going on in my head it's
like yo you got people to depend on you
you got to make this happen you gotta
figure it out you can't go to sleep
today because these people depending on
you you can't you know it's it's crazy
because you would think that it would be
just about you but it's not never right
you know what I'm saying so you know you
have to keep that dialogue going with
yourself and not mind you there's times
where people tell me oh you're doing you
know you're working too hard I'm just
like nah not really not really yeah you
know what I'm saying like I could I
could actually be going harder right
because the thing is you know I'm not a
doctor I'm not a lawyer I'm not an
athlete all these things that are coming
up is because I have an entrepreneurial
spirit and I'm creating I'm the
co-creator of my my future so I have to
think and and articulate these things
and I got to be able to communicate this
to my team like I want to do this but I
want to do it this way we should bring
this person in because they know what
they're doing and then and it's like you
have to be able to put people together
so they can work together right and get
them to understand that my vision is our
vision because whatever I can help you
do you're an executive okay well let me
help you be the best executive you could
be right and if you're uh into uh you
know you're the CFO like let me make
sure that this is easy for you to
understand yeah you know how how things
are coming in what's going out
um if you're you know the the a r
um Let me let me introduce you to some
people that
um you know that really do this that you
wouldn't even know right and you should
befriend them because they're going to
teach you things I can't even teach you
so it's just those things like building
your people up but it took
decades to find the right people because
I had to go through a lot of people and
understand everybody and you start with
your friends first oh man terrible you
know that feeling right he's right and
right yeah just you know it just don't
work and it's hard to tell somebody oh
it's the worst yeah it's hard to tell
somebody like yo man this ain't really
working out because now what does that
mean for us now we ain't even cool as we
used to be now you changed and you're
acting funny you acting different but
I'm like it's been my vision the whole
time yeah okay what do you want me to do
I can't stop you know what I'm saying
because if I stop it we all done you
know and I think the biggest and the
hardest thing for me and I talk about in
the book is that I had to turn my back
on everything I knew right and that was
scary because I had a support system and
I had a way that was set up that I was
able to take care of myself and my
family right so I was good so to speak
the only thing I had to worry about was
the feds and and not get into it with
the wrong person right but that's that's
a lot yeah you know it's everything
right so that was like you know the
trade-off is like okay well I'm gonna do
this
um but I gotta really you know like I'm
not a rapper like I didn't get up
writing Rhymes I didn't you know that's
that wasn't I just understood that I
could do it just like you guys are doing
the podcast if you had great
conversations like we just put a mic
here that's what happened exactly like I
know music so if you put me in a room I
can make it make sense yeah because I
know how to write yeah you know what I'm
saying you're the foundation the tools
yeah so I understood it and I was a
student of people that I like I was a
student of Tupac I understood what he
was trying to do he was trying to build
men men's Morales he was thug life was
more of a movement than what it sounded
like it was like we stand for something
you know he had morals and values and
grew up we didn't have people around us
with more than values they was going to
the factory to work or go wash cars or
something like they was happy to get you
know 60 30 and go to the liquor store
because that was a thing back then
everybody congregated the liquor store
under the shed and the liquor store
owner getting everybody checks yeah
everybody money you know you getting
beer you get like that was a big day you
know you get paid on Friday everybody's
at the liquor store but I go find my mom
she hit the liquor store and they
casting everybody's checks probably
getting you know six seven percent you
know maybe 10 who knows and and and that
was the thing you know what I'm saying
and for me I was just like yo that that
ain't that ain't for me though even at a
young age you saw us like I'm bigger
than this but also that's not the
arrogance talking it's just like I know
that yeah there's something more I knew
that something was wrong yeah I knew
something was really wrong with the
picture that was going on and that's
what made me really want to lean into
being a leader because I feel like if I
could do it then anybody can do it
exactly and I think even with rap I
think a lot of times you know they give
people their flowers all the time and I
think at some point they're gonna have
to come and say you know what when Jesus
came he came straight from the streets
see I came in the back door but you know
the average person would have locked it
back like they found it I left it wide
open blueprint and all here it is and
everything you've seen that came in
since I came in came in really straight
from the streets it wasn't like the
label according to somewhere and finding
these kids it was like they was coming
out of the neighborhoods and it was like
popping but I left the back door open I
didn't close it like I gave people the
blueprint I did it my way and it's like
well [__] if Jeezy could do it I just
seen him standing in the corner store I
know he's a regular guy like us and
everybody just you know just flooded it
so now my mission is um and my purpose
is to to lead by example right and so
um people coming from my Walk of Life
that you can't allow them to box you in
right you you you you marry who you want
you you live where you want you do what
you want you uh you think how you want
to think you know I'm saying you
associate yourself with whomever you
want to so like the rules are no longer
there because they're they're they're
not there for anybody else so they can't
be there for the culture you can't tell
somebody from Yale they can't get money
with somebody that came from Harvard
that's crazy
you know what I'm saying it's just
something like you know what I mean it's
just like why not you know and where we
from it's like I can't get no money for
him he's from the East side he's the
blood these are this he's that he's like
nah
we all grown man we gotta figure it out
we'll go to school together that's the
same thing we had freeway rickon and he
said that's what made him so strong
right he's like I didn't care about any
of the division I was trying to make
everybody with money across yeah and and
if if if it's up to me I want to you
know I want to
um you know align everybody with
knowledge you know what I'm saying like
you know I'm not the smartest person in
the world but I happen to know that I'm
a great communicator when it comes to
people who who talk my lingo right and
it's it's I can say it and and
simplicity is the key it's just like hey
this is what it is this is what it ain't
you know what I'm saying this is where
you at this is where we need to be and
it's just that simple and at this point
there's probably only like a handful you
can count them on your hands of artists
that have been around and so relevant
for 20 going 25 years like you're it's
just nice to see you at this point now
to be able to do this I'm like yeah your
your credentials just everything speaks
for itself at this point hey what's up
guys taking a moment to talk about one
of our sponsors and this is ship station
I have been a customer with ship station
for push trees for a half a decade never
left Never Gonna Leave before I had ship
station Rosie and I for push trees would
write down everything by hand it was the
worst trying to keep track of everything
in inventory ship station lets you run
every single thing on One dashboard it's
as easy as going on a social media app
and checking things and you guys know me
I'm not very technical I can use
shipstation easily shipping labels
tracking orders getting the orders
getting the money making sure
everything's going through making sure
it's not fraudulent shipstation can help
you with everything like I said it's all
in one dashboard if you've never tried
shipstation and you're a small business
owner do me a favor go to
shipstation.com right now use code dope
as usual two free months 60 day free
trial there's no headache no nothing I
guarantee you you're gonna stay over 130
000 companies use hip station 98
retention rate so once again take it
from me code dope as usual go to
shipstation.com code dope as usual at
checkout 60 free days 100 free we're
doing a thing with ship station right
now for the dope as usual podcast I
would never steer you wrong I've used
this for five years solidly go ahead and
try it out for two free months and see
how your business thrives
and I think I think a lot of and I was
uh and I tell people like even the
process of writing the book reading the
audiobook myself uh all those things
were very therapeutic because I had to
really like
relive a lot of the trauma you know what
I'm saying because I lost a lot I don't
think we really I lost a lot to get here
like I lost a lot of good men you know
I'm saying like a lot of great people
that was in my life but you know that
that that their casualties of War like
that's the war that we've been fighting
since we was born and that's just to
survive you see I'm saying so to be in a
situation now when you walk in these
rooms
um and you in these rooms in these
meetings the one thing that I have that
I know they don't have is for one is
integrity right and heart you know what
I'm saying and I know that I could take
pressure so I'm not going to be in the
fold the minute I'm getting some
resistance you know what I'm saying I'm
gonna figure it out I'm like okay you're
gonna let me in the front door I'm going
to the back so I can let me in the back
door I'm going in the window I'm getting
in here yeah you know what I'm saying
and that's my mentality so when I'm in
these rooms and we having these meetings
it's just like you know I'm I'm I'm a
Visionary and I'm a disrupter I'm
already
I can tell you what we need to be doing
now is my team's job to tell me the
details of how we're going to get there
but I see the vision this is
I see it this is where we need to be and
it's like that in those meetings because
a lot of those guys just know how to uh
broker Deals they don't they don't see
you know they don't they don't forward
think you know what I'm saying this is
like high level strategic or understand
the fans truly and how they're going to
react or what they want but even with
business I mean a lot of these guys just
kind of do with the the cookie cutter
thing is you know you have to be
Innovative yeah you know that's why when
you got the Elon Musk and um
and all those guys that are really out
here uh Jeff Bezos they're innovators
you know business is business but they
took it somewhere else completely
different you know what I'm saying
because they they see it they like okay
you know who nobody wants to go to
Walmart every day I don't bring Walmart
to you yeah let me figure this out okay
boom there you go I mean you gotta think
like you know seven years ago we was all
jumping in cash we have a ride it
changed the Earth right everything
you ain't gotta even get a car service
yeah you know what I'm saying so but
that was somebody who was an Innovative
thinker and they foresaw the the the
natural regular template of what
business is you know Hertz rental cars
was cool but that ain't that ain't gonna
touch this many people at one time so
how can I think of a way to get
everybody involved right and still have
it well you only got to wait a minute
two minutes to get a ride genius yeah
right Problem Solver of course I'm crazy
to the taxi cabs didn't like it but
however of course
it was just the whole [__] right they
were Blockbuster right there you go yeah
and I wasn't like that even with I'm
gonna be honest the only one I didn't
see coming like that really threw me off
for streaming because I would have bet
the house that would have never had the
DVDs but I don't want to stream I'll
give me the DVD yeah yeah and and and
even with you know the music yeah I
never like I would have been at the
house I was like nobody's going for that
because the artist hated Napster it took
a while to kind of make sense for the
artist oh I fought Apple music all the
way into I needed to hear some old DJ
Quick and it was like you can't buy this
song but you can get it on on Apple
music I'm like really what else is on
there everything you're like whoa
download it for me please you know yeah
would you say now the way things are set
up with streaming like it's way more in
favor of the artist to be able to go out
and make their own money with the label
deal right well no I think that there's
still a lot of tweak in there I think
there's uh still a lot of you got to go
through your books because you don't
they don't know how to scale it yet
right that's one thing because how do
you know right you're going by one thing
yeah they can tell you one thing to do
another and then artists for like myself
yeah I came in the game when I was
selling you know two million physical
CDs at a time imagine that so now I
didn't negotiate my deal to streaming
so I got records that are being
streaming mixtapes and everything so now
I got to go back and and and you know
what I'm saying I have to go back yeah
go through everything you know what I'm
saying audit everything because I wasn't
set up for that right
yeah this is like so it's so much money
out there yeah that I got to go back and
audit them for because I was set up for
physical CDs right wow and then even
these cats that you've seen that are
coming up that's why they're giving them
so much money because there's no way you
can you can actually get in there and
see what you're really streaming right
they can give you a number like you
don't have to yeah you don't have a
database
or whatever so it's almost like a game
now yeah because you know then you know
what you was getting charged because
they had to make this physical CD they
had to make the jewel case they had to
make the cover all that you got to pay
for that so that's probably about two
dollars or whatever that comes out of
your money right but with the streaming
it's it's like
yeah I hate to say it but it's like
streaming is like fentanyl you can make
it yourself
like I'm just being honest like you know
it ain't like you know you go to the
Coker Fields it and make this product
that's just there yeah they making this
[__] out of whatever and it's like
that's what it's like with streaming
it's just like it just goes and goes and
goes and goes and goes like who's there
who what what what organization what
company what who's there to make sure
yeah that you're like because when you
start talking publishing there's
confidence right right who's there for
strength make sure everything's on the
upper right because they'll tell you
like if you stream you know half a
billion streams it might be you know 4B
who knows yeah yeah
let me know
damn no let me this is a government let
me let me in something special here real
quick so we have DJ Drama on here okay
and he said we're going through his list
of favorite projects overall and he did
he say Lil Wayne was better than Trump
or die again
I boxed them in the other day you're
gonna quit saying that [__]
well
he said Trapper Dyer was the best
quality Street Music of all time okay I
must have got through to him yeah yeah
I mean he said he's like dedicated I was
like man give me three songs off the
dedication take you know I love Lil
Wayne when I come home bro like so that
whole era music for me like I always
saying podcasting we're seeing
podcasting do what hip-hop did like we
had 80s hip-hop Run DMC then we had 90s
hip-hop DMX Jay-Z we got 2000s hip hop
yourself right you know everybody else
and I feel like we're on that second
wave of podcasting right now we have
Rogan's generation coming in or whatever
yeah but in hip-hop my favorite era is
the mixtape generation yes and we have
two little things here we're hoping that
you'll sign for me
from my favorite air oh we got the smack
Joy this is going right up by Marty's
plastic they almost sent me to prison
like three times oh damn Smack DVD
almost got me in trouble bro all right
we'll get this thing away from you Chris
yeah it's all good oh question do you
smoke still uh yeah yeah dude I mean you
know I'm smoking my DJ today shout out
to DJ Ace that's what he does I got some
joists yeah of course okay cool yeah
we're so heavy I got a weak gun back
there yeah
that's that's that's what the [__] is
this it's a joint wow this is a what
this is a as you see this little Canon
feel free light that [__] up
that's a wedding or what it's just a
joint
bro I came from an era man Joyce was
like joints that is like
about to roll a pound joint for a video
soon I got this roll of paper that's
like a size of a bed and what's the
biggest one of those you ever smoked
before
biggest you can't go back you can't go
past a pound it doesn't you have to hold
it like this on cardboard to hit it
doesn't make sense you know but like the
ones you could smoke 100 grams only do
you get any oh I got this one story yo
this guy I was uh living in Malibu and
this guy was getting uh smoked from from
uh la
I used to get like a half a pound every
like month or so because I was up there
I was recording the house or whatever
and he came up you know one of the days
he brought uh he brought you know the
smoke for me but then he dropped off he
said I left you some gifts on the
counter I'm like all right cool so I go
over there it's like three boxes and
it's like uh they're uh gummies yeah you
know taffies so it's like great uh
strawberry or something else so I get
one you know I eat one kicking it you
know hanging out nothing happens smoke a
couple more blunts I eat another one
nothing happens you know everybody was
hanging out get another one I eat
another one they're good right I'm
sitting there and my mouth gets so dry
I'm like I feel like I'm about to die
like my mouth gets dry and then I go oh
[__]
and I thought about it so I go run over
to the box and I look at the Box
and lo and behold each Taffy I ate was a
hundred milligrams oh so now I'm at 300
milligrams and I'm losing my mind
see the Edibles are the only thing you
guys can get back from yeah yeah bro you
have to wait I lost my mind I did a five
thousand one once right 5 000 milligrams
yeah because I do we videos and [__] I
did 5000 ones and then it wasn't that it
was so high it was more of like you know
in movies where fools get beat up and it
goes black for a minute then it comes
back right they're like damn I'm at the
hospital that's how I felt oh [__] I was
driving what the [__] oh my God you
don't say a thousand milligrams yeah
like we do a lot of weed like content
that's what we do on the other side like
I do a lot of weed content and that [__]
did that exact thing like almost praying
like and please just take this [__] away
and stop the crazy thing I think I
talked about in the book as well uh back
when I was hustling or whatever
um
I had a cousin and she was you know
trying to get her a little money here
and there so what we would do when we
cut up the uh the Rocks is we was put
like a bag and we call it shake it'd be
like the crumbs and she was like she's
like yo cuz let me get the crumbs you
know what I'm saying I'm getting my car
wash and stuff I was like all right cool
whatever so I give her the crumbs and me
and my other cousin gold mouth we riding
around we hanging out there now I was
like man I want some weed he's like [__]
your cuz got some so I called her I was
like yo let me get some weed so I get
the weed from we riding around we listen
to Tupac I'm smoking I'm smoking he
doesn't smoke I'm smoking and I sit back
and I'm listening to the music sound
like it's chasing me like it's like it's
like it's like it's I'm the most
paranoid I've been I think I'm gonna die
he take me to the hospital
and I'm sitting there and I'm going I
asked myself when they got me background
said yo do you think she put those
crumbs in the weed 100 you feel what I'm
saying to make it more potent yeah but I
still didn't get the truth about it but
that I stopped smoking for like
I mean you know what it was was I was I
was more afraid uh
that because a lot of my friends you
know we started on hustling you know a
few of them started smoking crack uh you
know what I'm saying and and by this
time you know I'm saying I'm knee deep
in it so
you know I'm already like one time I was
I went to school after being around my
cousin and we was cooking all night and
all morning and I went to school and I
just had this crazy feeling like I just
it was just such an uneasy feeling and
I'm like I'm going through withdrawal
symptoms so I went to the phone booth
because I had to pay phones back then I
dialed this 1-800 number that I got out
of the phone book for a drug drug line I
changed my voice like Hello uh I think I
think I'm addicted to crack
could you tell me what I need to do I'm
being for real I was I was bugging you
were a kid though yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah the fact that you're cooking
Crown go [__] my studies all right I
gotta get to [__] class it's a
termination if I've ever heard it yeah
you know what I did I did this [__] that
I'm going to the gas station getting
high and I'm walking home right no that
was uh that was one of those biblical
moments but I was more you know I was
more like I got to stay focused because
I don't wanna you know I saw a lot of
people go out real sad man you know and
I felt for them but it was just like
that's one thing I did learn though the
only really thing I had a um an issue
with I wouldn't say it was an issue
because my both my parents drank my
mother's side of the family they get lit
like they get wasted and when I was
going through a lot of my my downward
spiraling like between uh trap or die
and thug motivation I did like I drink
excessively that's how I was
self-soothing right so it'll be a lot of
times I'll just make bad decisions
um or not do things you know I'm late
for everything I ain't on point I ain't
on time you were earlier today so you
were earliest yeah yeah that's why I
ain't smoking a drink but
um you know I was um you know I just
wasn't reliable and and um
yeah I caught it and then plus it wasn't
like helping my my health-wise I I um
around the recession is when I just cut
back on everything got in the gym and
you know it started going down from
there I went
did a show when I dropped the recession
in in Boston and I came out there man
and women were throwing their bras on
stage I'm like I'm staying here I'm
eating I'm eating clean I'm doing you
know what I mean like because it was
like that that changed um can you talk
about that in your book you talk about
routine and discipline what's your day
look like as far as that goes um well
I'm I get up 5 a.m every morning no
matter what no matter what hey y'all
don't work close I'm on no matter what I
do what time even matter what time I
went to sleep I get up uh first thing I
do is meditate for like 30 minutes I
feel like I'm doing that I've been doing
it for a while now then I go stretch uh
for like 30 45 minutes got to do that
you know what I'm saying but because you
because you got to be no you're right
right because the thing about it is like
when you do what I do you have to the
younger you feel the longer you can do
it right because you're traveling a lot
you working then I do that and then um
uh I get into my well as I'm stretching
I'll listen to my podcast to finish
reading the book or whatever I'm doing
uh with my headphones and then I'll sit
sit before the sun comes up and I'll uh
drink
um like six six uh glasses of water
right then I'll go to uh my hot lemon
hot lemon water and honey you know what
I'm saying just to clean my stuff and
then and then I'll go uh after that I'll
go to my coffee you know what I'm saying
which I don't even know how the hell I
got involved with coffee it just came
out nowhere that's correct I hate that
right I don't know how it happened you
know I'm saying somebody gave me
something like oh I could do this what's
better right are you puffing weed while
you're doing this in the morning
and then I um and then I'm off to the
gym I go to the gym box for I mean I go
to gym workout for like an hour come
back kick it with the fan for a minute
12 o'clock I'm back in the boxing gym
unboxing about five six rounds and then
you know what I'm saying I come out of
that and then I um and then I'm off to
my day oh then you start your day yeah
so what time are we at when you're
getting out of the gym uh well the first
gym I go in about eight something was
seven years yeah then I'm about I'm done
about eight then I spent some time with
the family then but either 10 or 12 just
depending on the day it is I go straight
there for the boxing and then from there
I just uh when I get done with that I
got the rest of my day so I get it in so
I got cause I got to be done about nine
eight nine because I gotta go to sleep
yeah yeah yeah yeah but but for me it's
you found it though yeah because it
would be like people would be texting me
and calling me and [__] and I won't
return no calls or emails or texts but I
learned when I got up earlier I got 30
40 minutes I could get all that done
right there I get my text done I got my
to-do list I know what I'm doing all the
people you get those seven points from
when you go and talk all these smart
people but that's 100 yeah because they
instilled that in me in the beginning
like your morning routine is is we're
really supposed to get ready the night
before because that's what's gonna
change everything
it's a morning routine but I'm just as
far as the clarity as far as the
health-wise as far because I hate
drinking water so it's like if I get it
all in in the morning I don't really
have to drink water during the day if I
don't want to yeah cause I already drink
like six glasses you only need six to
eight you know what I'm saying so if I
do one or two I'm good and then um
um as far as like Clarity
um when you're on a schedule like that
you're on a structure uh you just got a
lot of clarity because you're not you're
not thinking why you're tired like a lot
of times I was just like grinding
grinding grinding yeah somebody asked me
something you know I'm already agitated
I'm just like ah yeah you know I make a
decision I'm gonna wake up tomorrow like
[__] I'm glad to know I'm not the only
one who thinks that way oh yeah no for
sure that's exactly the thing like oh
[__] just do it yeah yeah I'm tired yeah
and then when you get up you're like
damn okay you know but for me like it is
crazy because a lot of my homies they'll
be with me they're like yo man you uh
you know like what time you get up and
I'm telling me like nah a bunch of my
partners are doing the same thing but
they're calling me like when they're up
like man I'm getting so much done I was
like you're not supposed to call between
yeah this is like your you time you know
right right right right you can't call
me before 10. you know that's all that's
right did you listen to David Goggins
books I I saw a lot of his stuff on
YouTube I thought was a monster listen
to a second book for sure okay yeah this
will just did the marathon my wife runs
married she got one next week oh wow
they do that 20 something mile [__] oh
yeah you own it like that then yeah
crazy bro yeah but he really inspired me
he's out of Buffalo he's like
yeah I didn't know that highly
recommended okay great man yeah I'll
check them out bro so my morning routine
like I smoke a bowl I checked my phone
no I was for a while and I hate that bro
like the phone's the worst thing it's
not even that it's not even just looking
at is the fact that if there's anything
like before you got to get yourself
together before you start taking any
energy in from the outside world could
you look at a couple of those emails
those texts you pissed off right yep
your day is already set you're on that
type of energy but you're completely
right for two months straight while I
was waking up doing my thing don't look
at my phone for the first hour and I
felt so much better I told you I fell
off I went to New York I was like I'm on
vacation yeah so what you're saying is
what I've been implementing more and
more and just I'm just trying man
I'm the one got it too was I don't got
into a science by far I just you know do
the best I can you know what I'm saying
but but at least gives me like I got an
anchor somewhere like I'm not just
floating because it was a while like I
was just emotional just whatever I'm
bored yeah or I'm you know I sleep but
uh my whole thing was I sleep when I die
I definitely don't feel like that right
now my bed is the most the most valuable
thing in my life right now if you show
it to me I'll show you that before I
show you my Rolls-Royce look at it it's
beautiful
it's like a thousand count on my street
you know that's what Coggins talks about
he's like when I'm resting but I'm at a
rest area I am resting yeah and when I
go back out I'm on yeah but that's
that's how I think about it too right
that's amazing what he's been able to do
like turn his himself around like I
don't believe anybody bullied that guy
it was crazy that's what I said like you
were the you were the [__] ass for I
don't believe I don't believe that don't
believe it it'll bite your head all of a
sudden he's crazy but you got your
routine down you got everything going
down you're passing knowledge off so
this point in your life right now right
I feel like if I can ask feel like
you're gonna say yeah like you probably
feel better than you did in your 20s
yeah yeah and and not just I feel
healthy and I feel uh
I feel more at peace you know because I
had to give myself uh permission to
evolve because a lot of the time I was
looking for validation
um from the people that I was around you
know because I wanted to accept that I
was a little smarter than they knew I
was you know what I'm saying they had to
know I was someone smart because they
were I didn't get caught up in all the
things that was going on because I was
Forward Thinking why everybody else was
just doing I was just like no I'm not
buying another Ferrari I'm gonna put my
money in music I'm not doing that I'm
gonna do this and it was funny because
everybody used to laugh oh he's the
rapper the rapper it was it was a joke
and then as soon as everybody started
getting indicted
my career took off he's like could you
imagine sitting in a Cell there's no one
could be oh my God bro like I had so
many nightmares about that bro like if
I'm not even if I'm being honest like I
used to wake up and like just pools of
sweat and it was just it was terrifying
man because it was just like that was
I was almost waiting on it I was almost
for sure and when
it got to the recession is when I was
like I don't think they're coming
I'm saying that was three albums in you
know what I mean
I've said a lot of [__] right like I
don't think they're coming man I was
like I might as well just go ahead
because if because people who did
interviews with me just be like
seemed so depressed I was like what does
that mean like I don't know what that
you know because I didn't paranoia yeah
I'm depressed I'm going through it but
it's just like you know I'm just like
you're just like this and I'm down and
there's no energy around me and I'm just
like you know I'm there but I'm not
there yeah I'm with 100 people but I'm
still alone you know what I'm saying all
that was going on dude when I just woke
up one day I was just like man you know
what I'm gonna write this out because at
the end I started reading and um just
getting into what was going on in the
world because I'm gonna be honest it was
some days I didn't even know what the
date was I didn't know if it was Monday
Tuesday the 13th no feeling ever yeah
but I I didn't even care doesn't matter
because I was ready yeah like I Ain't No
Cap like it would be sometimes I was
flying in the plane somewhere I was like
man I just hope this [__] fall down
because I ain't want to deal with all
the stuff that I had going on right yeah
yeah it's a lot of it just it was just
so real right and it wasn't until the
recession where I was just like man like
I'm good I'm I got a future I got a
career you know what I'm saying I I'm in
a space where I feel like I can handle
this and I just want to write an amazing
project and I just went in and I wrote
the recession which which to me is
probably one of my better better my best
projects
um because of the time it took and then
also
um just the understanding I had because
I started to like read a lot more
understand what was going on in the
world and I just was having
conversations with people so I would get
the knowledge and put it back in the
music because I was in a room with a
bunch of business guys
um they were well off and they was like
yo and the recession comes we got to do
this and I'm like well y'all got money
like why would y'all be worried about
that and it was like because and they
started explaining me like what the
recession was and I'm like wow that's a
drought it's just a drought on the money
you know what I'm saying so that's why I
wouldn't put it into music because I was
like let me go warm my people you know
and that was the message is like this is
a recession this is real you know what
I'm saying okay you know what I'm saying
let me tell you about it because I got
the knowledge from them yeah so let me
tell y'all yeah
and it happened boom what's kind of like
when people like they can't hear from
their parents they got to hear from a
friend right yeah it's the same thing
like yeah yeah tell me this oh you
[Music]
was that like Parker used to say things
and I I wouldn't have took that from
nobody else yeah it's a fact exactly you
know totally for me it's Makaveli what's
your favorite Tupac album uh Makaveli as
well yeah Makaveli and I love Thug Life
the Tony had with the Outlaws and um
because all eyes on me is just like I
think that's just more mainstream but
Makaveli was yeah yeah and the fact that
he even knew to go and because when you
hit when you read up on Makaveli you're
like damn you know what I'm saying he
was a different type of dude yeah yeah
so for him to want to embody that even
back then he was that much 24 45 years
old thinking like thinking like that
yeah so totally now we got to get you
out of here but I just need to know
you've worked with all the greatest that
I've ever existed you got songs with
Jay-Z you worked with every producer
that's ever made a Beat
who stands out to you and the booth was
like this [__] is damnation as
far as now ever ever oh you're a
musician this is your this is coming out
as a town this is gonna sound crazy but
I think the greatest musician in the
world is Sade oh wow yeah
like jeez
something else bro like she's like I
listen to her music sometimes and it
just take me a like it just takes me out
of any type of stress wow yeah and I and
I got that hanging around the older
Hustlers and they would just listen to
it with the you know they they uh fly
outfits and they Diamond rope chains and
I just be like damn I want to be like
that you know what I'm saying so I
always go back to Sade and that's like
my vacation music if you ever see me on
vacation there's some Sade going on you
know good [__] that's a good to feel
real Miami Vice you know I'm thinking
about calling me right I think they
think that's what the Mexican cartel
listen to everything but
um I know we got to get you out of here
but uh August 8th August 8th at verses
for sale uh by by your boy Jay-Z Jenkins
you can get it right now pre-order
everywhere books are sold that's Amazon
audible any of that and uh you know
August 8th it goes down man and I
appreciate you guys for having me thank
you thank you legendary ass I can't
believe you smoked we used to smoke
about six on the show we saw
oh one question I gotta ask because I
don't think anybody's ever asked you
real quick before we leave what's your
favorite rock group my favorite rock
group uh gotta know what's his favorite
rock music man
I would say Bon Jovi would be
but Pink Floyd is good [__] I said last
night you're sitting fluid Led Zeppelin
or Pink Floyd on behind yeah good [__]
all right all right well thank you so
much
legendary thank you podcast for Marty
Jeezy and I have a dope ass day dope
yeah good [__] Pink Floyd
[Music]
perfect